Atchoum
Bah, excellent! Yo tout le monde, c'est Squeezie!
Aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur "what inside the box?"
Aujourd'hui on va jouer à un casse-tête chinois les amis. Vous avez déjà joué à un casse tête chinois? Quand vous étiez petit c'est sur que vos parents vous en on offert un.
En espérant se débarrasser de vous pendant au moins une heure.
C'est parti! C'est 30 énigmes à l'issu des quelles on verra ce qu'il y a dans cette p***** de boite.
Ok, 1er casse-tête, c'est des boutons, on allume les 4 et on passe à la suite.
2eme enigme; il y a encore un bouton... bah voilà... on a juste à déplacer les formes et appuyer sur les boutons
Non mais on en est vraiment là ?
Alors... donc ça c'est un compteur de boutons et en haut il a des formes, il faudra mettre le nombres de côtés 2, 3, 4, 5; 1, 2, 3; 1, 2, 3, 4.
Holala mais qu'il est doué! Mais qu'il est doué! Mais dites le!
On a pas de doute, on sait très bien que Squeezie le génie trouvera la solution...
...mais pas la modestie!
Alors il faut faire un rond. Nan mais les gars on est en quoi? La on est en CM2, on est en quoi b***** ?
Ha merde... j'ai parlé trop vite.
En fait lui, il peut que allez en haut et en bas, c'qui est très chiant.
Ha bah voilà!
J'ai trouvé c'est bon! En fait il fallait juste cliquer la, du coup on a fait monter celui la, et celui la on peut le ramener
Ouiiiiiii
Attend mais mec, qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça? Peut être qui faut appuyer sur les deux en même temps en mode vitesse, attend...
Est ce que vous avez une idée? Comment on fait b***** ?
Pour moi, logiquement, ça voudrait dire une fois, puis  non, puis oui
Voila je sèche là, c'est pas possible. On est à 6 sur 30 et c'est dur comme ça!
Allez, je veux un indice
Ouais, désolé, nan mais la c'est trop dur...
"Utilise les flèches"
Si ça se trouve, en fait le carré c'est une flèche de gauche et une flèche droite et la croix une flèche droite et gauche qui sont collées.
On va voir...
Donc du coup j'pense faut faire clac, gauche gauche, droite droite droite, gauche gauche gauche, droite droite, et on reclique.
Enorme fail.
Nan mais j'pense que ça se joue qu'a la souris, du coup ça ça veut dire gauche et ça droite. Voilà c'est bon, ouh !
D'accord on est à la recherche des boutons, ça deg.. voilà ! et ensuite, hop on en parle plus ! Attends c'était easy !
Là bah on va appuyer sur tous les boutons
Ahhh d'accord
Bah ça c'est le chemin qu'il faut faire voilà, tout simplement
Voilà on en parle plus !
Fallait faire un "2"
Easyy mon gars
Alors qu'est ce que l'on fait avec ça ?
il y a un truc le long du bouton ça doit indiquer si c'est le premier ou pas
par exemple là y a un seul truc lui c'est le premier, là y en a 2 lui c'est le deuxième là y en a 3 lui c'est le troisième
Et on en parle plus !
Abonnez-vous !
là je suis super chaud je suis "on fire"  alors ho là qu'est ce qu'il faut faire là ?
bah question 10 "ten" en anglais c'est ça ou pas ?
cette satisfaction j'ai l'impression d’être un génie mon gars
alors là par contre j'rigole plus  trop qu'est ce qu'il faut faire ??
en faite quand j'appuie une fois là c'est lui qui s’allume quand j'appuie là c'est celui d'avant
quand j'appuie là 2 fois c'est lui qui s'allume
*rigole* c'est super dur à expliquer
donc le but c'est de faire 1, 2, 3, 4 hop 1, 2, 3 hop, 1, 2 hop
1 hop !!!
Et c'est fini, et vous avez rien compris
c'est ça qui est génial dans les vidéos de squeezie
c'est qu'on comprend rien
furo, rezo, neo, c'est dans une autre langue c'est sa ?
furo , reso, neo,  furo, reso, neso, nazi.... neo, nazi quoi?
Est-ce qu'on partirait pas sur heu... essayer toutes les possibilités?  Hein... comme des bons gros cons.
Franchement si t'es malin tu l'passes en f'sant ça hein... j'suis désolé
c'est pas si long franchement une combinaison à trois chiffres
tu fait le tour des possibilités rapidement....
One !  neo ça fait one !
P***** on est cons on est cons
Oooh j'suis désolé...OOH le con !
Rezo, là c'est quoi ? Zzz...zero ... p*****...
Et furo c'est fff...quatre...four...
Rhoo...
Bah ouais j'ai plus fait de casse-têtes depuis que mes parents veulent plus se débarasser de moi
Donc
Bah c'tait hier mon dernier
Alors!!! là qu'est ce qu'il faut faire ? Faut emboiter les pièces?
Elle dans...elle...
...dans elle...
et dans elle.
Ok.
Hahaha!!!! Je l'ai eu
en faisant au pif!!! Ah vous voulez savoir la logique??
Je suis désolé... T'es au-dessus casse-tête quand t'arrive à le résoudre
sans que ça te casse la tête. Vous voyez ce que je veux dire???
Ohhhhh... Quel est
le f*uck? Quelle est la corrélation entre
ces boutons?!
Ça c'est fait.
Alors ah cette fois je peux me permettre
on se fera pas baiser les gars. Ça par exemple vous voyez si je
mets la souris là vous vous rendez bien compte c'est gauche, haut,
droite, haut haut, gauche et droite
Ah là c'est un double! Putain c'est chaud
Nan là c'est chaud par contre. Nan bah nan c'est pas chaud regardez c'est bon.
Faut mettre lui là. Hop hop
hop voilà. Hyper simple celui-là! Il n'avait
rien de compliquer. Oulala!!!! On part sur unnnnnn....
J'ai l'impression de... t'sais de pirater le digicode d'un immeuble.
07, 10,
70, 17. Zéro et donc le zéro
c'est quoi?? Arrête Van Damme!!!
Le zéro c'est quoi? Je comprends pas là. Un,
deux... J'crois que j'ai compris.
Donc là c'est 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9
Zéro. C'est comme ça sur un digicode.
Zéro, sept, un, zéro, sept,
zéro, un, sept.
...Voilà. Suivant.
Ohhh putain j'ai fait genre mais putain qu'est ce qu'on est content!!!! Yes!
Yes!!! On résout une énigme
d'enfant et on est heureux putain c'est beau! Attends
nan mais là, nan mais là arrêtez  un moment de nous prendre
pour des... hein. Hop
hop hop voilà
Ah là j'vais t'dire fallait pas être
hehehehe... News??? Attends celui-là
il est dur il est redoutable celui-là... Ah il me pose une colle!!!!!!
Bon un indice, un indice. Là vraiment je sèche.
"Wind directions" La direction
du vent... Pardon? Ah!!!
North, East, West,
South!!! Okayyyy!!!! Faites pas semblant
personne n'avait deviné. Et ouais les gars
Ouais ouais ouais c'est vrai ouais... Oula qu'est ce que c'est que ça?
Ah faut que j'les mette tous d'la même couleur!! Oh ça j'adore ça on adore!
Mais c'est easy. L'énigme pour CE1!!!
Apparement, à force de simplifier le bac,
dans 30 ans le bac ça sera ça.
J'ai mon bac. Clac. Clac vers
le haut. Lui en bas
Quand j'vais cliquer sur celui-là ça sera la fin donc je vous explique avant.
En gros tu suis le sens. Le rond signifie le point de départ
donc c'est celui-là. Tu vas en bas à droite puis tu vas en
haut. Puis tu vas en bas à gauche --de celui-là tu vas en bas à gauche-- puis tu
vas à droite. Voilà. Squeezie le prof.
"Box". Ok faut faire des boîtes donc les angles
on les met comme ça. Et là vous allez croire que j'ai cheater mais j'vous
J'vous assure que non! Et avant de m'accuser
d'tricher regardez déjà si c'est la bonne réponse...
...Ok j'ai triché
C'est faux!!!! C'est faux. Nan vraiment pas en plus. Alors là!
Comment on fait??? Ahhhhh!!!! Il y a une histoire
de boutons plus de... Olala
Anhhhhhhh! Là... Je comprends pas
le rapport entre les boutons et les pièces
...Voilà.
C'etait deux... Okkkk jai compris!!! Les
boutons représentaient les cotés
de la pièce où y'avait un...
C'est super chiant. Changez de vidéo.
Alors coeur, "v", flèche,
coeur. C'est peut-être par rapport au nombre de lettre qu'il y a
dans chaque mot? C'est pas ça. Peut-'être
par rapport au nombre de côtés?
...C'est pas ça.
Alors là je sèche... J'parle pas d'mon linge. Ok
j'veux l'indice j'veux l'indice parce que là ça me parait un peu débile
"mirrored numbers"
4 nombres inversé? Quel numéro face à un miroir donne
un coeur? AH!!!!
Ça c'est un deux!! Ok c'est les lignes, c'est les lignes
qui ont bloqué ma vision. Clac clac
C'est un sept! Vous voyez le sept tu le retournes
et tu le dupliques. Ça par contre c'est un....
Il est pas homologué ce chiffre
Ah si c'est un "1"
Et fallait trouver!
"new sense". C'est quoi ça? Ah bah
est-ce que c'est pas comme tout à l'heure??? East, North,
South, East.
Ahhhhh le mec il recycle c-ces énigmes!!!
C'est génial!!! Bon tant mieux pour nous on va pas s'men...
Alors vous voyez ça c'est pareil c'est comme tout à l'heure c'est le départ.
Droite, haut, gauche, haut,
droite, haut.
Et c'est la fin!!!! "bob box" faut faire une boî-boîte!!!!
C'est une boîte dans une boîte mec. C'est sûr...
On parit combien??? OLALA!!!!
Même la caméra elle a été impressionnée par cette énigme. En gros
fallait faire une boîte dans une boîte. Les amis nous sommes maintenant
proches du but... Qu'est-ce que c'est que ce bordel???
Ahhhhh voilà la solution!!!
Voilà. Blanc, noir, là il faut un
blanc. Et là...
Bon niquel c'est bien tombé. 29!!!
Il va falloir tout remettre de la même couleur? C'est ça? Ça c'est l'énigme...
Voilà. Pack 2020 c'est fait!
"Count up all" what?
Ahh ok. Par exemple "O"
C'est la combien-tième lettre dans l'alphabet le "O"?
J'ai du me gourer!!!!
Ah non ok ok ok c'est plus complex que ça.
Il faut effectivement trouver la
combien-tième lettre ça représente dans l'alphabet et ensuite faut juste
cliquer dans l'orde. Le "E" est avant le
"F" qui avant le "N"
qui est avant le "O" qui est
avant le "S" qui avant le "T".
... Mais c'est sûr que c'est ça.
Comment on peut faire? Nan mais là.. y'a... à mon avis y'a... ça relève
de l'anglais en fait. C'est pour ça que j'y arrive pas.
Nan on termine sur un fail? Nan....
Ok je viens de comprendre.
J'ai du réfléchir longtemps ça m'énervait de pas comprendre et
d'terminer euh... le jeu sur ça. "Count up all"
Il faut cliquer sur
la première lettre du chiffre de chaque niveau.
One, two,
three,...sixteen, seventeen,
eighteen,...thirty.
Ok.
Y'a quoi dans la boîte? Montre moi.
...des bonbons.
Vous m'avez pris pour un putain
d'âne. Je m'en bats les couilles des bonbons.
Tu m'aurais mis un Pikachu dans la boîte à la place des bonbons j'étais refait!
Bon voilà les gens c'est déjà les fin de cette vidéo sur
"what's inside the box"!!!!! N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plus!!!! Bah écoutez
c'était bien ce petit jeu: ça changeait, ça nous a fait réfléchir un petit peu,
ça a fait travailler notre matière grise. J'vous à très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo! Merci d'avoir regardé! Portez-vous bien! Ciao tout le monde!
Peace!